bachelor in paradise starred mario  jackson speaks out for the first time  production on season four of the hit  bachelor spin-off halted earlier this  week due to allegations of misconduct on  set the incident remains under  investigation  de mario released a statement to ET on  wednesday addressing the controversy  quote it's unfortunate that my character  and my family name has been assassinated  this past week with false claims and  malicious allegations I will be taking  swift and appropriate legal action until  my name is cleared  this comes after Corinne released her  statement to ET that read in part I am a  victim I have little memory of that  night  Corinne also wrote she is dealing with  the physical and emotional trauma  stemming from that evening stick with et  for the latest updates as this story  develops  [Music]